i know your wife your wife is a very
healthy
eater yes and does she got you is she
got you trying to be healthy i mean you
know there's times you know when i feel
like i'm i just gave up i mean you know
i don't even at times i feel like i'm
trying to get fat you know like
like a couple nights ago i was eating a
pint of ice cream and uh
i finished it because i'm american you
[Applause]
off the know and i threw it away because
i'm not a quitter yeah right
and because i care about the environment
i was conserving energy by not
refreezing it
and i've never heard that argument
that's fantastic it's a good one yeah oh
so i was eating uh pine ice cream and
sweatpants like a man yeah
and my wife came in the room she was
like jim are you gonna eat an entire
pint of ice cream by yourself i was like
hopefully yeah
unless you selfishly want a bite she was
like jim you have a nine-year-old
daughter don't you want to be at her
wedding i was like not really no
no wait is there going to be ice cream
at her wedding
how would attending a wedding why would
that be an incentive you know it's like
don't you die in 18 years there's an
awkward party you have to pay for
i'm going to write a check
so she wants you she wants you to live a
long time yeah you know i love my wife
and and i love the fact that i have
someone that's looking out for me and
she wants me to live longer but you know
we all want to live longer but how long
right
i mean you ever see old people i mean
really old people they always have that
look on their face like
i can't believe i'm still here
i would have eaten so much more ice
cream
[Laughter]
why did i ever consume kale
you know kale kale can we stop with the
kale propaganda
kale has become i never heard of kale
and then in the last couple of years
it's kale it tastes like bug spray
that's
that i looked at a can of bug bug spray
and it said made with real kale
it's a chaos so good for you it's just a
trend right kayla's so good for you you
know they could find out kale cures
cancer and i would still be like i'm
just going to do the chemo
how bad
no you bring up a really good point
because i every time i eat anything now
it's got kale in it i don't know i don't
know it's like california thing or
that's also in new york they put kale
everywhere well and it's also people
brag it's just a health trend like
there's a new health trend every six
months there's a new milk every two
weeks you know like you're not supposed
to drink cow's milk don't drink cow's
milk you should drink soy milk and they
discovered soy milk is all estrogen
they're like do you should drink soy
milk unless you want your sons to have
testicles you know you should drink rice
milk and they discovered it's all it's
like drinking carbs and they're like you
should drink almond milk because almonds
make milk
unless you have a nut allergy
then you should drink hemp milk which is
like a nut-free almond milk that's made
from rope
and if you don't like that you can try
this new milk that's called cow's milk
very big in europe
but i don't know i did discover that i'm
gluten free i don't know if anyone's
gluten free here no wait you discovered
you discovered that you're allergic to
gluten or well i was lying that person's
a communist
obviously people that are allergic to
gluten are just like anybody else in
this country etc they're allergic to
wheat
the amber waves of grain conan
doesn't mean they don't love this
country it just means they can't stomach
the purple mountain's majesty
those are the people we should be
screening at the airport yeah right
are you gluten free slash a terrorist
that's pretty rough i don't know it's a
good idea really wow well now that you
art your eyebrows like that i'm agreeing
with you yeah why not so uh so yeah so
you are so gluten-free you you you live
that way that's tough i'm i'm trying to
do the healthy thing but it's just you
know i think it's whole foods right i
blame whole foods they're just bored at
whole foods they're like all right what
else can we sell these idiots
give me a plant not that one that's
poison ivy
wait can we make milk out of that you
know
they're just like kale kelp charged 20
bucks for it and we're like all right
okay we don't care they don't know we
don't know